[Music]
hello and welcome to tier hanket John
there's that first thing of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where me
and member the town answer your question
give you do B suffice to bring you all
the week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon how you doing John I'm doing
well thank you
I just received in the mail 378 tumblr
stickers from tumblr oh and actually
from tumblr tumblr
yeah from from tumblr itself and I I
feel like this 378 things joke has gone
a little bit too far well I mean we got
a back away from Hannah what are you
gonna do with 378 stickers give me
something I could eat
tumblr yeah well I candy bars some
tumblr hot pockets
you know it some tumblr salad dressing I
don't think when I think about the
places where tumblr needs to expand and
change I really I do think about food
first they need to get in the hot pocket
business because I just feel like the
current hot pocket business is not being
well served by only having one brand in
it oh yeah I do not see enough social
media representation at the grocery
store what is that about
that's so not Twitter you know what are
those things called TV dinners Twitter
TV dinners that's what I want
mm-hmm they're just it's just they're
all a hundred and forty calories each I
mean one of the things I really like
about having because my brother Hank is
that even when I have kind of very
mediocre ideas you're wonderfully
excited about them and I really
appreciate that
oh well I got really I got really
excited I think I think Twitter's busily
got a huge opportunity uh yeah I agree
the biggest problem that twitter has is
not being in the TV dinners business uh
Hank would you like a short poem for
today before we do that John I have to
say that you got your stickers from
tumblr but I from so now from two
different sets of fans of the pod I've
gotten candy and one was the Orion's
that
we're Irish potatoes that have no potato
in them and now I have received just
because you were are always getting the
good stuff and people feels feel bad for
me I assume I just got 378 peanut butter
cups what
not from Reese's just from people who
want me to feel better about my lack of
good cam man that's not fair
I love Reese's Cups exact du you know
what John do you know what I have put
them out for all of the staff at
complexly Missoula to enjoy unlike your
policy with your poor people in
Indianapolis who just got to look at and
not touch the Snickers ah okay I don't
I'm you know ha ha ha don't don't try to
paint me as a bad guy just because I
wanted to enjoy all 378 of the Snickers
that the Snickers company sent to me
personally ah well we are different
people that's all that's all I can say
do you have a short poem well yeah
that's that's not that's not at all fair
I am a I am a fantastic person who just
happens to love Snickers and also I
would not ask for someone else's
Snickers you know I believe that in in
this world a human being has to pull
themselves up by the bootstraps and
without any help find their own Snickers
in this world you know we've all got an
equal shot at Snickers yeah I know
there's also the fact that if I had 378
Reese's peanut butter cups in my home
that next week I have about 50 and an
eID but I would have serious digestive
issues so yeah I do need help with this
problem it is it is a bit of a problem
to have that many Reese's peanut butter
cups I would I would say that you know
some people would construct it as a
problem other people would construct it
as an opportunity here's a short poem
it's by Bill not a poet I've gotten
really into since he died I feel bad
because it's so cliche to get into poets
right after they die but I didn't know
about him until he died anyway this poem
is called alternative fates and I really
love it what if right in the middle
of a battle across the battlefield the
wind blew thousands of lottery tickets
what then what then Inc like scratch off
tickets like they're not done are they
are they already are they winning
lottery tickets or like that have been
like or are they just like okay
everybody has to get their coins out the
city wasn't by definition they can't all
be winning lottery tickets it's been
it's not a lottery it's just a straight
cash giveaway that would be more
expensive than the actual probably not
wars are astonishingly expensive it's a
good point John all right what do we
gotten in the way of questions from our
listeners this fine day on dear Hank and
John well this first question comes from
Danny who writes dear green brothers any
time I cook something in the oven that
requires a covering of aluminum foil I
noticed that even after 40 plus minutes
of exposure to extreme heat the foil is
barely even warm when I remove it this
is weird isn't metal supposed to be a
good conductor should not the foil be
just as hot as the metal dish in which
might delicious lasagna is being cooked
is everything I learned in my chemistry
courses about conductors and insulators
a lie any dubious explanation is
appreciated victory for the forces of
democracy Danny I feel like I just was
asked to participate and propaganda by
reading the sign off I've been tricked
Hank yeah you guys you're not getting a
hundred percent like read of sign offs
we will skip them sometimes if we find
them controversial enough but not that
one victory for the forces of democracy
John might and democracy have been
overrated
do you like the frame that the fort like
victory for the forces of anything
really like maybe we shouldn't be
framing things that way or is that the
it was I wouldn't mind like victory in
the war I don't let's move on so Danny
to your question that if you were
listening extra hard in in your
chemistry / physics classes you you
would you would know one extra thing
about he
which is that it's there but it is also
it is only there in the amount that it
can be there so if I have like a piece
of lead that's like 30 pounds and it is
uniformly heated to you know 450 degrees
or whatever your oven was at then that
object has a ton of heat inside of it it
isn't just a temperature it also
contains a lot of heat and then if I
have like a feather that I have well
that's a bad example cuz it's gonna
catch fire at 450 degrees probably but
if I have something that is very light
that I heat up to the same temperature
then that will be the same temperature
but it will contain less heat so when
you're talking about this tin foil tin
foil is very light it's very thin so
when you touch it you are actually
touching something that's 450 degrees
but all of that heat immediately like it
just isn't enough to heat your finger up
very much what so it's going into your
finger there's just not enough heat to
change the temperature of your finger
German no oh there is no I thought it
was because aluminum is something
special and different from other metals
there's no way that is the answer the
answer shut the front door
so yeah I even looked it up because I
was I wanted to make sure I mean I you
know what Hank I support you and as you
know I'm a huge fan of science victory
for the forces of science however
there's no way that's true Danny it's
because aluminum foil is different from
other metals that's why and nobody knows
how it's different or why it's different
but it is okay well we you know you're
just because you just because you don't
agree doesn't mean it's not true but
we'll move on Hank if I've learned
anything from recent American history
it's that if you believe something that
is legitimate no matter what even if
it's wrong it is as legitimate as a
right as a right opinion because
opinions are just opinions and everyone
has them and facts are just facts and
there might be alternative facts that
contradict your facts and there's a lot
of data out there and the data isn't
clear and aluminum foil is special and
different and you just don't understand
it or maybe
doesn't understand it yet because it's
so complicated and interesting that
science hasn't been able to grasp it so
let's move on questions for John who has
steer Hank and John I'm a delivery man
and I started giving people reminders of
their mortality along with my pizza am I
good it could happen at any time
John no no you're not good not good
nope nope you're you are on the wrong
side of history friend here's my issue
with this Hank I mean I have one issue
okay all right I want you to imagine a
pizza delivery situation in which you
open the door you hand the money for the
pizza
the pizza is handed back to you and then
somebody says you could die at any
moment what I'm gonna take from that is
not like a helpful reminder of my
mortality I'm going to assume that I am
about to be murdered yep I mean I also I
want to know how this message is being
delivered it's very vague like like yeah
are you being super subtle because even
if you're saying if you look at me at
the end of a pizza exchange and you just
even if you say it could happen at any
time I'm gonna spend the next like six
years freaked out over like what is it
yeah I like to imagine that there's just
like before he puts the pizza in the box
John just writes a little message just
just it could happen at any time like
very small under that and so you're like
99% of people aren't noticing it but
like somebody takes that last piece of
pizza and then they're like what is that
what is that what is it what does it
mean the piece of what is the pizza box
trying to tell me John
you have to stop doing this this is big
big concern for me yeah though I
definitely will not order a pizza again
from a restaurant that delivers with a
pizza delivery man who is also
delivering a message of my own mortality
like it's just have you not noticed like
a dramatic decrease in repeat customers
reminders of their mortality along with
pizza I mean if there's any time like I
understand that we should be aware
the finite nature of our existence but
yeah so we have sundials I don't need
this right now
like I'm yeah I've already made a
mistake today
I'm already indulging myself hey hey
stop right there stop right there all
right we think you and I have both now
said stupid things in this podcast that
we just need to stop and apologize for
first off I expressed an opposition to
democracy I would like to take that back
okay I am hard in favor of democracy I
don't know where that came from
and then now having said that Hank I
want to give you an opportunity to take
back the horrible disgusting
reprehensible thing you just said about
pizza I take it back I do not want to
shame myself or anyone else for the for
the enjoyment of the perfect thing that
is pizza thank you thank you okay all
right we are I feel like we're back to
even now and aluminum foil and science
being wrong but whatever we'll just
ignore that
oh I'm not I'm not walking away from
that one it seems like you must be wrong
I believe that you're right but it also
seems like you must be wrong which let's
move on to another question Hank all
right actually you know what I'd like to
formally apologize for saying that
science is wrong but I don't know if
people can read tone anymore these dark
and strange times so I just want to be
absolutely clear that I'm I'm Pro
science this question comes from Emma
who writes dear John and Hank I have a
distinct problem for the first 16 years
of my life I thought my name was Emma
that spelled EMM a however upon my
attempt to acquire a learner's permit I
found out that there was a clerical
error on my birth certificate making my
legal name Emma that is Emma spelled
with three eggs
mmm-ma to be clear this spelling was not
intended by my parents however they seem
to find my mutant beast of a name
absolutely hilarious
and take every opportunity to remind me
of it obviously I am distraught the
problem with my name is causing an
inordinate amount of anxiety for me I
mean is it better now that we're
laughing at you Emma and perhaps it's
something philosophical about the
teenage struggle for identity no I don't
think it's that I think it's maybe that
your name is spelled EMM ma how is it
pronounced no John how is Emma worse I'm
having a hard time figuring out if my
fears are legitimate thus I've turned to
the pod a great idea
so am I being too uptight should I
pretend this clerical error never
happened or should I own the new
spelling well I don't know it's just
like hey why is your name Emma with
three M focus like sixteen years ago
somebody misread a form okay but John I
was I just want to point out that that
Emma signs off the quality of Mercy is
not strained
Emma or possibly M but rosianna has put
the person's name at the top of of the
question as she does yeah and it spelled
it with three ends I mean up I believe
it's pronounced Emma Emma right Emma
Emma Emma I think it's no I think it's
just M oh that's what it you're ab c--
right you just have to you have to
settle more into the must but it's like
um yeah that's not bad by the way that
quote is from Shakespeare and it's a
very good sign off um it's really lovely
and so if nothing else you've got a
great sign-off going for you which is a
wonderful start and then I think that
probably the next step is yeah you
should go ahead and legally change your
name to the name that is your name
because the government should not get to
decide how many M's are in your name I
don't want to sound like too much of a
libertarian Emma but I do think that
there are some places that the
government should stay out of including
the number of M's and Emma do I mean do
just stick with it stick with the three
because who else has that who else has
that story everybody from now on is
gonna look at you to his lesson thinking
to be like I didn't know your name about
three M's in it and you're gonna be like
funny story and also I was on this
podcast and they told me to keep it so I
did though one of the brothers was wrong
and he told me to change it and I
disobeyed him directly and then I wrote
a letter to Hank about how right he was
and how great he is not since I said
that aluminum foil can't can't be judged
by science have I heard such do biasa t
that's ludicrous that's terrible advice
Emma I mean look the thing is Hank she
will have the story for the rest of her
life
all she needs to do is like comodo copy
the birth certificate and keep it in her
pocket for the rest of her life she's
gonna have a hilarious story
I mean Hank is right Emma that this is a
very funny story like I understand that
current you is really unhappy about this
situation and I don't blame you because
it is an unpleasant situation to be in
at the age of 16 when you're trying to
get your driver's license future you is
going to find this as funny as your
parents do and like so there is you need
to hold on to some memories of Emma but
I don't think you need to hold on to the
name as your name if you don't want to
all right I feel I feel as if we have
both made our cases this next question
comes from comes from Cassandra with 3
s's dear Hank and John recently me and
my boyfriend broke up due to
irreconcilable differences a couple of
days ago his name was Ryan and I'm not
even joking I'm generally doing ok post
breakup however this situation has left
me with a serious quandary who gets
custody over the teddy bear we made
together at build-a-bear cinnamon sticks
and hockey pucks Cassandra does he want
it I mean does anyone want you know in
the long long long run is this not a
bear that would be best suited with an
entirely new family I mean have you seen
the ending of Toy Story 3 that's where
we're at here yeah I think we're in a
Toy Story 3 kind of moment no spoilers
and I
I think that maybe in the even in the
medium run it might not be that helpful
for you to have the bear and I don't
think it would be that helpful for him
to have the bear but I do think it would
be helpful for somebody to have the bear
who could really love that bear and and
care for it in fact if you like the
problem is you don't want to throw the
bear away you don't want to say oh you
you bear I'll take the bear do you want
to send me the bear I'll pay for no Hank
that's no Hank you are not a good home
for the bear I guess you could give it
to Orin on the other hand I would submit
that Orin among the world's children is
perhaps you know baird up yeah I mean
he's probably reasonably beared up so
maybe donate the bear somewhere I feel
like well the thing is it's like a
custom bear it's got like it's got
memories of this particular situation
inside of it you know people are
probably a surplus of builder bears that
have memories attached to them that
people feel a little bit weirded out by
but anybody who's listened to this
podcast I feel like they'll be aware
enough of the story that they'll want to
you know give the bear a good home and
avoid any you know nasty custody battles
okay so if you listener are in a
situation where you need a bear a
build-a-bear bear high-quality
build-a-bear bear available now by the
way this person has not agreed to make
her bear available but Hank and I think
it's the right thing to do let us know
on the patreon at patreon.com slash dear
Hank and John you can access it even if
you don't donate if you need a bear yeah
what you would need a bear for and we
Cassandra if you are ready to say
goodbye to that bear if this
relationship is really over and it
sounds like it is I think maybe if
you're willing to give it up and nope no
pressure if you're not we can find a
good home for it the bear's name is
Crawford by the way Crawford the bear
made at Navy Pier in Chicago it sounds
like a lovely inside story but I think
that the I think that there's a there
are happy resolutions that can occur
I agree I am inclined to agree it's
still it's a sad situation I had a
similar issue with an actual cat not a
stuffed cat but a live cat named pants
when my college girlfriend and I broke
up and the pants situation still bugs me
let's move on to another question from
Rachel who writes dear John and Hank
i recently went out with some friends
and the phrase came up beer before
liquor never been sicker liquor before
beer and you're in the clear I feel like
this is not actually a thing since it's
just all ethanol right it simply depends
on how much you drink have you
experienced this phenomenon and do you
think the saying is true still alive
Rachel well I'm glad you didn't die of
alcohol poisoning : maybe that's just
just generally her sign off not to do
with the specifics of this question I
feel like as a sign-off here's my issue
with it as a sign-off it is a little bit
redundant right yes well you are typing
at the moment so there is that's my
concern you Hank I you and I are going
to answer this question differently
because you presumably have done some
like scientific research on it whereas I
have something more powerful than
science called anecdote hit me with that
anecdote buddy boy
so I've I've gone both ways and my
experience has been that if you drink a
lot you will feel sick and you will feel
sick the next day and once you hit about
the age of 37 you will also feel sick
the day after the next day yeah so don't
just don't drink to excess and if you
find yourself like regularly drinking to
excess and not able to not drink to
excess you have to pursue not hangover
remedies but instead treatment options
well I will so so I there definitely
isn't a lot of hard science here there
may be something to the fact that you
might get a little more water with your
drink if you are if you're drinking beer
a second because maybe you drink longer
as
the thing it's definitely a
psychological thing more than it's a
hard science thing I think that when you
are drunk you drink more so when you're
not drunk is definitely true so so if
you start with liquor and then you're
like I'm a little bit drunk and then you
move over to beer it's harder to get
really really drunk on at least you know
your average American beer I mean it's
super possible super oh it's not that
it's not that hard but I think but it's
easy it's it's easier to know what
you're drinking when you're drinking
beer whereas when you're drinking liquor
you know shots like a shot glass of a
slightly different size can have way
more alcohol in it a you know a mix to
drink can have way more alcohol in it
like you don't really know how much
alcohol is in a mixed drink so I think
it's easier to drink more when you're
drinking liquor I don't think it's
impossible to drink a lot when you take
a beer but I think that that is that is
where this this saying came from is that
when you once you are drunk if you
switch to beer you're getting a little
bit more water with your drinking and
also you may not be you may not end up
drinking as much as if you get a little
bit drunk on beer and then you switch to
liquor and start going way way overboard
and not knowing how overboard you're
going because you're already drunk so
that's I think that's where it comes
from but like absolutely you can get
super sick both ways and so drink do not
drink to excess because it's not fun
it's fun it's not no a few years ago my
my best friend Chris gave me a piece of
advice that to quote Gatsby
I forget the quote I've been turning
over in my mind ever since I think
anyway the piece of advice was this we
were at a party and I had a beer in my
hand and Chris looked at me and he said
you know what nobody ever regretted the
next morning and I said what and he said
not having the last beer it's a great
great point I want to thank Chris I bet
if you follow that line of reasoning all
the way down you never have any beers
well yeah yeah this certainly comes of
regret but it's good advice especially
when it comes to the last beer I also
want to thank John for really just
cruising past
the part where I called him buddy boy
and not making a big deal out of my
weird decision there I literally didn't
hear that but it's just one more example
of how extremely dubious this entire
episode of the plot has been this
question comes from Emily oh wait did I
read the last one you did this question
comes from Ben who asks John poor Emily
I will get there I was considering a
YouTube red subscription however I don't
know if it's worth the money I recently
saw Hank go on a lengthy Twitter spree
about YouTube bread I'm nervous about
the side effects
how much do creators make off a youtuber
without ads Ben ah well let me summarize
quickly we get a percentage of the
revenue that you give to YouTube and a
YouTube red viewer is definitely always
worth more to a creator than a
advertising-supported user like at least
two or three times more although in the
current environment with ad rates I
would say in the toilet is perhaps an
understatement like whatever is below
the toilet is the YouTube ad situation
at the moment yes somewhere it's
somewhere downstream from the toilet is
the YouTube bad situation you know I
think at this point it's kind of at the
sewage treatment plant and they're
trying to figure it out trying to make
it a little bit yes gross before they
that's exactly correct so I would say at
this point YouTube read viewer it might
be worth 5 - some creators even 10 times
as much as a as an ad-supported user so
certainly YouTube red is good for
creators yeah but but also like if you
know if you don't know if it's worth the
money for you like I think it should be
worth the money for you oh absolutely
and if you want to help creators
supporting them on patreon goes way
farther than even a YouTube red
subscription well like a hundred times
further yeah I mean you I have YouTube
red because I like it and because an ad
free YouTube is worth it to me and also
because it comes free with a Google Play
Music subscription so I was able to get
rid of my Spotify subscription which I
will never say again if Spotify just
agrees to sponsor this podcast how
until they do I'm gonna tell you the
truth which is that I got rid of Spotify
for google play music and then it
basically got YouTube's bread for free
and I'm kind of confused why everyone
doesn't do that but maybe maybe lots of
people don't have paid subscriptions to
Spotify I'm not sure which brings me to
the fact that this podcast is brought to
you of course by YouTube's bread YouTube
you bread
sure why not ya know it's like it's like
Spotify plus add for YouTube that
actually that actually sounded like a
proper sponsorship Hank that was closest
well we didn't get paid for that we did
we do kind of get paid
yeah but indirectly more more to the
case this podcast brought to you by
patreon a place where you can support
really great independent creators
directly and a very very small
percentage goes to the upkeep and
maintenance of patreon actual business
because they are really creative focused
and they are great patreon.com slash
dear Hank and John we've got to get rid
of the actual sponsorships though Hank
let's today's podcast is brought to you
by build-a-bear custody battles
build-a-bear custody battles coming soon
to a theater near you the podcast is
also brought to you by messages of
mortality which was were brought to you
by your pizza delivery man brutality
available now inside of your pizza
apparently and most importantly today's
podcast is brought to you by the forces
of democracy the forces of democracy
just to be absolutely clear I'm in favor
of them okay poof of course all right
this question comes from Emily who
writes Dear John and Hank hey guys okay
so I have this problem my problem is
that for as long as I can remember my
uncle has always greeted me by asking
Emily Mae what the hey every time he
sees me like the rhyme itself is not a
problem in fact I find it to be cute my
issue is that what the hey is just not a
thing that people ask each other what
does it even mean I'm not sure if it's
even hey like you know like hey or hey
as in hello how am I supposed to answer
this nonsensical question what the hey
Emily John do you know that here in
Montana we have a thing called what the
hey
which is where
know if this is everywhere where they
dress up hay bales as like minions or
like snow man or whatever no I'm not
familiar with they call it what the hay
and everybody makes l-man and they've
it's like minions have totally taken
over what the hay it's so like it's like
not it is a bit disappointing but
there's some really great what they have
if you if you google what the hay ajy
you could see some good good Montana hay
creations but I don't think that's what
Emily's uncle is referencing I think
what Emily's uncle was doing in all
likelihood is saying something that he
has been saying to Emily may since she
was like 0 years old like like Chris
always sings this song whenever he sees
Henry he sings Henry Atticus mnf in
green
and until until Henry was like - he sang
the actual song if you catch my eft and
then and then he he has since then
censored it but like it is so far it's
just a result of having spent a lot of
time with someone as a baby and like
singing nonsense songs to them and
saying nonsense things to them to get
them to sort of babble back at you and
so Emily Mae what the hey is your
uncle's way of trying to say I love you
in a way you can only imagine that you
cannot even fully glimpse because for
much of the period that I have been
loving you you were like you know
semi-conscious so I think I have to
respond to it just by saying like I love
you Uncle Joe or maybe just be like uh
you know Uncle Joe what do you know like
maybe think of a rhyme that involves his
name
good advice John I appreciate that and
I've now I feel bad that I don't have
like fun names for from name rhymes for
Henry and Alice I'll work on it this
question is from anonymous dear Hank and
John I'm a high school senior and this
week I was rejected from four colleges I
got accepted to a couple but all the
ones near the top of the list did not
accept me I'm trying to stay positive
and remind myself that I have a
wonderful opportunity to choose between
schools that did accept me
but it's hard because all these
rejections make me feel a lot of
self-doubt any advice through this
process would be really helpful you both
mean a lot to me crumbling under the
weight of my own existence
anonymous hey did you get into all the
colleges where you applied well John I
only applied to two but yes yeah I mean
so I applied to like a bunch of colleges
well here and I here's the secret of
getting into only two colleges John I
did apply any good schools well I mean
you the school you went to is it good
school but you didn't apply to any like
Ivy League schools or anything yeah I
wasn't trying to get in any place like
super special yeah I think that where
you go to college is important but maybe
not for the reasons that you think it
will be important when you are a high
school junior or senior a lot of times
like where I went to college was very
important but I also didn't get into
probably the five best schools I applied
to and I'm very grateful for that
because if I hadn't gone to the college
where I ended up going I would not have
moved to Chicago after graduating from
college and I would therefore not have
met Sarah and I would therefore have a
vastly different life so like when I
think about what was really important
about college like the classes were
really important I learned a lot of
things that I've been able to apply to
my professional and personal life but
the single most important thing was
geography that allowed me to meet my
wife yeah I mean like I I also think
that there are a huge number of great
schools there are and there are a very
small number of schools that will help
you just through virtue of their
reputation right and and and I and I
almost think like in terms of like
that's kind of weird anyway like if
you're being helped just by the fact
that you went to a school that peopled
like recognize the name that doesn't
necessarily say anything about what you
learned but they're like overall there
are a lot of great schools in America
that no one's ever heard of and and you
will have no idea whether or not
a school is good for you until basically
you're done but I think as long as you
like come into it with the with the
right mindset and the right goals and
like and want to take on college with
sort of an open mind and a spirit of
like I like this is exciting and I'm
going to going to make myself a better
person for these next four years like I
think you're gonna get a lot out of
school wherever you go yeah I mean there
are definitely some colleges where it's
easier to get a good education than
others because they're you know
student-centered or
you know or or learning the centered or
whatever easier to get different a good
education in different subjects but I
would argue that the vast majority of
American Universities are places where
you can get a good education so you're
gonna be okay I remember being very
disappointed about the places I didn't
get into although I got into the college
I most wanted to attend even if it
wasn't there like technically the best
according to the rankings but also I
wouldn't put a ton of stock in those
rankings I think oh yeah you know it's
measuring the quality of an education is
not something that numbers are
particularly good at doing I agree John
do you have another question for I don't
but I have a number of responses to
things first you might remember it Sarah
of the Girl Scout cookies she wrote it
to say
Dear John and Hank it's Sarah the Girl
Scout and I wanted to let you know you
guys know that with your help we managed
to donate 78 boxes of cookies for the
food pantry which is really great it's
not 378 but it's still a lot so thank
you to everybody who donated and bought
Sarah's Girl Scout cookies through the
link that we read out loud that has
really made me very happy then a number
of people wrote in on the topic of
snakes because we suggested I guess to a
kid named Devin that Devin sneaked a
snake onto the campus of Devin's new
college that turns out to have been bad
advice at least according to
number of college administrators who
wrote in to let us know that in general
snakes are not welcome in in dormitories
really I feel like there's got to be
like some dorms that allow snakes and I
feel like luminol file must be
chemically special but apparently I'm
also wrong
Susan wrote in as well to say Dear John
and Hank I don't have a question I just
wanted to thank you it's one of the best
emails we've ever received Hank I met a
guy with the tattoo that says more
Ettore teh salutant
because I had just listened to the
podcast where you explained what that
means I was able to show off my
knowledge and this Friday we are going
on our second date IRA's and otters
Susan I mean it remains to be seen
Susan whether it is proves to be good
news or bad news that you are going on a
second date with someone who has a
tattoo that says those who are about to
die salute you but I hope that it works
out I think it's a I think it's a pretty
cool Latin phrase and I think I mean
just don't feel pressure from us to get
married
ya know that's definite definitely not
we're ok need yeah just the date is good
enough for us
yeah we're delighted about this
situation can I read to you a quote from
from 800 different emails that we got
yes it's just just a direct quote it was
in the all 800 of them uh-huh john OMG
yeah it's bath bomb not bath ball yeah
come on I know I would like to apologize
to my friends at lush cosmetics for
calling their bath bombs bath balls
however I would also like them to
apologize to me Hank and I waited until
the end of the pod to tell this story
because I don't want to in any way
damage the amazing reputation of my
personal sponsor Lush Cosmetics however
one of the bath bombs so I've been using
these bath bombs pretty regularly and
they're fantastic you can find a picture
in fact of me using one of them on the
patreon at patreon.com slash dear Hank
of John however one of the bath bomb
it was shaped kind of like a ello and
white pill and I put it in my bath and I
was like oh this is so lovely I am just
having the most relaxing experience and
then at the very center of the bath bomb
there was this sort of silvery stuff and
I was like that's weird god what a great
bath I'm having and I had like a nice
30-minute bath and then I got out of the
bath and I love this story already my
beautiful lovely wife who is not totally
sold on this whole me using bath bombs
in every bad thing looked at me and said
John you are literally covered in
glitter was I covered in glitter but I
would say that I like five days later
there is still a fair amount of glitter
on my body oh that's awesome I love that
we also done there's like a good pocket
inside of it yeah oh there should be a
special warning the other day John this
has started to happen to me this is a
very unrelated but I I was drinking what
it would appear to be seltzer water then
I started to feel like I had had some
caffeine and I looked and there was
caffeine in it
it wasn't branded as an energy drink it
was like branded as like a low-calorie
soda thing and I was enjoying it and
like you can't just throw caffeine and
stuff and not put it on like the front
label and say caffeine in this and I
also had a cliff bar that had caffeine
in it and I know you can't just you
can't do that to a guy I freaked out
okay that's that's just like having your
entire body covered in glitter except
it's just my soul that's warmer me
formerly your [ __ ] is form of
caffeine former former here I'm gonna
get in here at some point for running
faster Tom wrote in to say dear friends
a couple episodes ago you answered a
question regarding signatures in which
John's old signature was brought up and
then Tom
has a copy of Looking for Alaska from
March 12th 2005 which is like less than
a week or I think nine days maybe after
the book first came out and that has my
old signature on it and we're gonna post
that on the patreon so that you can see
what my old signature looked like
second-to-last we received several
emails from friends or acquaintances of
fort the fourteenth most powerful
Canadian Gerald bus an astonishing
number of dear Hank and John listeners
know either Gerald Butz himself or our
friends with Gerald butts or slow-danced
with Gerald Butz his friend Justin
Trudeau when when they were in high
school it's it's absolutely overwhelming
the number of people who know Gerald but
it makes me think that Canada is indeed
one of those countries where literally
everyone knows literally everyone else
and lastly lastly and wait you gotta you
gotta give that you gotta give their
best that best little note at the end of
that one John what is it that Gerald
buts
what if you're wondering really loves
bruschetta oral however that's
pronounced I think it's pronounced I
think it's bruschetta but I'm not
totally positive however that is a
little bit of Gerald Butz trivia for you
Gerald Butz fans out there and lastly
and perhaps most importantly we've
received the following email from Sarah
Dear John and Hank
Jeffery potater s'en has become
self-aware Jeffrey potater said who if
you're a longtime hardcore listener
2-tier hanka John you will remember from
a previous episode after months of not
accepting friend requests from literally
hundreds of listeners Jeffrey potater
s'en has accepted all of our friend
requests and has become like pretty
excited about his popularity found
platform yeah yeah posted it he posted a
Jeffrey potato son is feeling excited
haven't been on in a long time
didn't think I'd become so popular oh
it's good yeah I noticed that I noticed
when he added me as a friend and then
immediately I started getting messages
from people on Twitter being like
Fred's lieutenants at Hank it happened a
listing again and I'm just so happy for
just so happy for Jeffrey potater s'en
hey what's the news from Mars oh right I
know the news from Mars this week do you
know which news from Mars I'm gonna give
you I hope it's the news where while
talking to an astronaut president Donald
Trump promised to get a human being on
on the surface of Mars by the end of his
administration hey you know that wasn't
gonna be my news because I feel like
that bought more what he's saying then
like I'm gonna get you to Mars in the
next four years is I plan on being
president for the next 75 years no he
said it he'd like it to be done in his
first term but it will definitely be
done in his second term which means it
would happen by 2024 which also means
that I'm gonna throw this out there and
I don't I don't we don't like to get
political in the pod but I don't know
that President Donald Trump has a great
sense of what it would make to get a
human being to Mars of like what exactly
Mars is no I think he knows what Mars is
I don't think I think he is a I think he
is a person who likes to make bold
promises yes he does yes mmm yeah what's
the news from Mars it's great news that
doesn't seem doable to me
I'll be honest with you I am pretty I'm
not very optimistic about hitting my own
date but it's interesting that he would
yeah he'd just say that without like
talking to anybody at NASA at all about
where we're at with the Space Launch
System which is not ready to go to Mars
any time but anyway I guess I wish him
luck I was going to talk about so we're
building things on Mars is important
because you have to have places for
people to live and and taking things to
Mars is very hard and so we would like
to take as little as possible with us
when we go to Mars so
a we have now been able to in the lab
create a fairly good substitute for what
Mars soil is like or dirt on Mars or
wreck regolith or whatever and they have
been thinking you know would be great if
we could build structures out of the
stuff that's already on Mars that way
not only you know they'd have the place
to live but also we could protect
astronauts from cosmic rays and and so
like maybe we could make bricks from
from the regula on Mars and the you know
the thought was we'd have to bring some
kind of binder with us or we would have
a microbe that would like turn because
on earth you can't do this like you need
a binder to make up to make clay into a
brick or a bunch of heat and etc so we
bring like a microbe that would turn
like human waste into this by-product
that we could mix with the soil and then
and bake it and turn it into a brick but
they found that actually because of the
iron oxide in Martian soil if you just
press it if you just take a bunch of
Mars soil at least the simulations for
it that we have right now you just
compress it really hard the the iron
oxide will sort of break down into like
flat little sheets and then stick to
itself because it likes to likes to be
with itself and so it breaks underneath
like a flat things and like tiny
microscopic structures that will create
a like a brick like structure and it
requires as far as we can tell no extra
ingredients and so you just have
automatic Martian bricks and all you
need is to apply a fair amount of
pressure but the kind of pressure that
could easily be applied by an electrical
press of some kind and boom Martian
bricks to build houses out of which is
exciting that is very exciting you know
what is not exciting oh the month of
April Hank every month every football
team has this thing where they every
football team in the whole world is like
every month like let's vote on our goal
of the month like here the top three
nominees for goal of the month which
which of these amazing goals will be
that you know our team's goal of the
month AFC
Wimbledon has not scored a goal in the
month of April going like well we're
safe so let's just yeah it's fine
there's there's there so they're
enjoying being safe so much that they
have now gone five five games without
scoring a goal during those five games
they've picked up two points both nil
nil draws against one against Swindon
Town won against Peterborough they lost
three nail to Bradford City a score that
from the accounts I could find on
Twitter seemed to rather flatter AFC
Wimbledon and yeah and now they are
about to play their sixth game of April
and hopefully maybe on April 30th they
will score and then there will be a goal
of the month because it will just be a
one goal and you can pick one they could
fight it out between the two goals of
the month yeah so I mean look the great
news and it is really great news I don't
want to minimize it is that AFC
Wimbledon are safe they are going to
have another season in Ligue 1 the bad
news is that if if you could be judged
on how you finish well let's just say
you shouldn't be judged on how you
finish one game left in the season for
AFC Wimbledon and it is against Oldham
another team that is completely safe and
also is playing for nothing so maybe
we'll find a way to win it or not lose
it or even lose 2-1 the quick so John
yeah are you gonna be below the the the
the MK what I wasn't very likely going
to finish below the franchise currently
playing it's trade in Milton Keynes yes
it's not it's not inevitable Milton
Keynes sitting on 58 points AFC
Wimbledon sitting on 56 so if Wimbledon
win and Milton Keynes lose then it would
happen otherwise probably not we'll see
we'll see there is still something to
play for because I think that's would
not be an insignificant accomplishment
all right John
what did we learn today well we learned
that there's nothing special about
aluminum foil its heat itself that's so
weird
and we learned that if the people at the
hospital put a name on your birth
certificate that's your name and and
that's great and you can be a my if you
want to be but also according to Hank
you have to be M regardless of whether
you want to be didn't say have to I just
so that's a good story
oh it's a great story we learned that
you should never ever ever tell people
that they are going to die while
delivering them a pizza and we learned
that drinking to excess is bad no matter
what you use to do it with John thanks
for potting with me today well we're not
done potting just yet Hank because we
gonna have to go records this week in
Ryan's our hit comedy podcast that's
available only via our patreon a
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
this week you know we're discussing this
week Hank oh no no I didn't realize you
had one but that's how it works
I picked the Ryan's and then you quickly
read their Wikipedia pages while
recording the podcast this week I've
chosen to make it very hard for you by
talking about Brian babble the Dutch
footballer Oh God if you want to ask us
a question you can do so at Hank and
John at gmail.com or you can use the
hashtag dear Hank and John on Twitter
where Hank is Hank green and I am
occasionally John Green but mostly Leon
must for earth or sports with John this
podcast is produced by rosianna halse
rojas and shared at Gibson it is edited
by Nicholas Jenkins Victoria Verona is
our head of community and communications
and our music is by the great gunnarolla
Hank thank you again for potting with me
and thanks to everybody for listening as
we say in our hometown don't forget to
be awesome
you
[Music]